hello freak [ __ ] yeah all the way
around on both side because I'm not a
big conspiracy theorist I should be but
I got should be be I I guess that
there's always more going on than we
think but I also think that most people
are too dumb to not get caught almost
every single time yeah you say that but
there's a lot of [ __ ] that happens where
people do get caught eventually and you
realize oh how long were you guys
running this what's your favorite
conspiracy theory that turned out to be
true it's hard to say whether it turned
out to be true but JFK is the biggest
one and where did you land on that I
landed on that it's very possible very
possible that Lee Harvey Oswald was
involved it's very possible the other
people involved too it's very possible
that he shot at Kennedy and other people
shot at Kennedy at the same time and
then he was a patsy and he was put up
like she was obviously involved in a lot
of intelligence agency shenanigans he
went to Russia he married a Russian
woman came back to the United States he
had been involved in all sorts of
communist propaganda [ __ ] he was
definitely not like an aboveground guy
he was a shady dude and it's entirely
possible that he was one person out of a
plot to kill the president and they put
it all on him than they had Jack Ruby
shoot him but everybody goes black and
white on that you either go Lee Harvey
Oswald acted alone
or you go he was innocent and the CIA
had him assassinated because he was
trying to get rid of the CIA
which he was I mean Kennedy was trying
to pull us out of Vietnam trying to get
rid of CIA he was trying to give her the
the the the Federal Reserve his there's
a lot of like super controversial ideas
that Kennedy was trying to push forward
and someone killed him I always go to
this simple thing which is why would
Jack Ruby shoot him right yeah cause a
lot of people say oh he was just a
patriot who got mad and happened to be
there but I which maybe makes perfect
sense but if he was told to do it it's
such a suicide end up in jail for the
rest of your life mission yeah it
doesn't get to me it falls them things
like that fall apart
there that's a but it's also possible
they told them listen just shoot him
we'll get you off will we'll find some
sort of away or they might have had
something horrible on him Jack Ruby was
clearly embedded in the mob the mom was
angry at Kennedy because they helped
Kennedy win they helped him win Illinois
yes you know I mean they helped him
become the president and there was
absolute evidence that they were mad at
him once he became president because
then he started doing things that were
against their interests there's a lot of
people pissed off at Kennedy
[Applause]
[Music]